Децентралізація - "найуспішніша з українських реформ",
заявив у 2018 році спецпосланник уряду Німеччини в Україні Ґеорґ Мільбрадт.
Вона почалася ще у 2014-му. Були запроваджені нові адміністративні одиниці -
об'єднані територіальні громади, скорочено "ОТГ".
Так місцеве самоврядування отримало повноваження та ресурси,
які раніше мали лише міста обласного значення.
17 липня 2020-го в межах децентралізації Верховна Рада
скоротила кількість районів в Україні шляхом їх укрупнення.
– Власне, парламентом було ліквідовано 490 старих, неефективних, диспропорційних,
маленьких, великих районів, абсолютно неефективних,
і створено 136 нових укрупнених районів,
кожен із яких буде не менше 150 тисяч населення,
що відповідає, власне, європейській системі статистики
і підходу до формування субрегіонального рівня.
Також уряд затвердив 1470 об'єднаних територіальних громад.
ОТГ наразі покривають 100% території країни,
і їхні зовнішні кордони тепер збігаються з кордонами районів.
Розглянемо новий адміністративний поділ на прикладі Волинської області.
Тепер область поділена на чотири райони:
Володимир-Волинський, Камінь-Каширський, Ковельський та Луцький.
До складу районів входять 54 об'єднані територіальні громади.
Раніше Волинська область складалася з 16 районів.
Реформою децентралізації передбачена концентрація основних коштів і повноважень
саме на рівні громад. Об'єднані громади вже мають право
розпоряджатися 100% єдиного податку та податку на майно.
Натомість на районному рівні залишається утримання об'єктів комунальної власності.
Ключова місія району – координація роботи різних інституцій
для ефективного виконання державних програм.
На рівні обласних адміністрацій залишається
політика розвитку регіону, питання екології та утилізації сміття,
підготовка професійних кадрів для регіональної економіки,
утримання великих обласних лікарень.
- Раніше ж голова районної адміністрації фактично був виключно людиною
голови обласної адміністрації, тобто діяв принцип:
васал мого васал – не мій васал.
Тобто президент призначав за поданням кабінету міністрів
голову ОДА, а голова обласної адміністрації уже формував
своїх у підпорядкуванні – 15, 25, 27 голів районних адміністрацій.
Теперішній етап реформи децентралізації має покласти край
пострадянській регіональній вертикалі.
Відтепер Київ матиме зв'язок з областю, районом і з кожною громадою,
тому що будуть прямі міжбюджетні відносини з кожним рівнем.
Це посилює вплив і відповідальність громад,
однак водночас зміцнює їхній зв'язок із центром,
що має запобігти сепаратистським настроям. Також
впровадники реформи впевнені, що ця система має побороти неофеодалізм в Україні.
– Обговорення, що нам не потрібно районного рівня, -
це певною мірою загроза з точки зору федералізму.
Чому? Тому що тоді посилюється дуже сильно регіональний рівень.
Тоді, власне, починається така регіоналізація, яка була в Україні до 2013 року,
коли області віддавали на відкуп місцевим елітам,
коли була сильна обласна рада з величезним мільярдним бюджетом,
із сильною адміністрацією, голова якої призначався з місцевих еліт.
Місцеві вибори 25 жовтня 2020 року мають відбутися
вже на новій територіальній основі на рівні громад і районів.
Також на цих виборах обиратимуть старост сіл.
Утім, ще багато питань, зокрема і стосовно бюджетів,
мусять бути виписані законодавцями в Києві.